today President Trump revealed his plan
to rollback limits on military gear for
law enforcement reversing President
Obama's policy that banned armored cars
high-caliber weapons and so on remember
all that when the media made
militarization the big bad wolf their
misguided emotion portrayed enhanced
security as somehow threatening when
it's only goal was to prevent violence
by presenting overwhelming strength
speak softly big stick it's highly
persuasive it's like the rhetoric Trump
uses with immigration a forceful
position becomes the wall reducing
illegal crossing police armed with the
best gear is similar stopping violence
without causing any they become a wall
between order and anarchy what happens
when that wall is missing well you get
Charlottesville you get Berkeley in
April and you get Berkeley now where
there's no order there will be blood
President Obama saw the gear as
intimidating but who does it intimidate
I'd say the people about to do bad
things but President Obama has always
viewed the world through the prism of
radical politics so he sides with that
Club Trump's the reverse everything seen
through the prism of law and order which
explains the wall militarization
boosting defense pardoning our pay Oh a
singular vision can be flawed but the
bigger picture can excuse the smaller
mistakes
Trump won because of three words law and
order ignore that Democrats will win
again in this case hindsight isn't just
2020 it will win 2020 Wow I decided to
add that extra flourish
Kimberly toss into that yeah Kimberly
yeah builder ization was a fancy word
for extra gear that creates a perception
of force so you don't have to use force
isn't that the logic well right but the
thing is they just I have this very
strong opinion about this having you
know worked as a prosecutor so many
years in Los Angeles and working getting
details and all that the police need to
have the tools that are necessary in
order to do their job and guess what
some of the things that people were
saying oh we can't have this and
stripping the police departments of the
tools they need to do their job it's
like taking us up the scope away from a
doctor just doesn't make any sense some
of these vehicles and the things that
are armored etc that are all-terrain
that can even go through
Daria's yeah help in times of a natural
disaster like this and really provide
relief to a community so why would we
want to take that away from them because
we want to say the police are bad we
don't want them to have any of the
things they need I mean they're not
going to have uniforms next are you
going to take away bulletproof vests I
mean what else just leave them with the
rubber bullets yeah there's always that
argument Jesse like if you give somebody
enhanced security they're in they're
inherently more dangerous because they
they're more with like a guy within
seatbelts will drive faster so the
argument is if they have more of it
stuff they're just going to be more
dangerous when in fact they're just
trying to protect themselves so they can
protect you
yeah the hardware is mostly defensive in
nature and it started when we saw those
images after Ferguson of these police
officers and tactical gear facing off
against these shirtless angry protesters
and people didn't like those images
especially in Obama's base so he
resented this deal Trump does one on law
and order and now he's delivering the
goods look at some of these things
military-grade bulletproof vests armored
vehicles tactical helmets tactical
shields a lot of these things that are
happening out there in the streets
increased gang activity violent crime
rows in cities over the last couple
years under the last administration and
tifa's running wild so I think some
Democrats think for instance we're going
to use the police these weapons against
them while they protest the RNC know
these things are used with explosive
detonations active shooter situations
large-scale riots terrorism situations
drug raids gang raids these things are
not your run-of-the-mill squaring off
against one lonely protester and a lot
of these things came in handy
you said it these armored vehicles they
use in Houston during these floods one
of the guys on the police side was
wearing one of these military-grade
helmets would actually saved his life
during the Orlando nightclub shooting
and then you had the armored vehicles
that were used to hunt down the San
Bernardino killers so and they're not
making new purchases this stuff is being
transferred so they're not paying this
is recycled hardware I thought Democrats
liked recycling can I say that liberals
love recycling except when it comes to
giving a
for the police right remember when the
Baltimore mayor said that we should give
the protesters room to destroy yeah
well the cops have to be able to respond
to terrorism rioting and they can't win
because if they are not prepared like we
saw in Charlottesville then they're
accused of not being able to handle a
dangerous situation but they've been
accused by the Obama administration of
being overly militarized and having too
much equipment and hurting the feelings
of criminals who really want the room to
destroy as a Baltimore Mayor suggested I
think we need to point out as well that
this is something the Obama
administration allowed to go on for
seven years throughout his term didn't
rescind it until 2015 it was in place
during the Clinton administration and
the George W Bush administration so
Trump really isn't doing anything that
out of the ordinary by defaulting back
to the previous policy Richard this is
an insane policy maybe I'm the only
voice of reason at this table but let me
say not let's take let's take a city
like Haverhill Massachusetts probably
never heard of it but they have 65,000
residents they have because of this
particular act 20 ton they have 20 of
these taught like these 20 ton Mine
Resistant Ambush vehicles tell me why in
god no tell you honest Haverhill massive
sunny why need 20 20 ton Mine Resistant
Ambush is another small city right
outside of Boston that was the scene
where the Boston bombers fled and in
2025 ambush vehicle vehicles to destroy
any 21 G all right how many 20 how many
of those that's what we have the
military we have military base village
in all the state is a crime that right
here's the problem with that not a one
military here's the problem that I'm not
the only person that agrees that this is
egregious lightly Senator Rand Paul also
feels the same way when you get feels
that bad when you get me excuse me and
when he gets back to the Senate he's
introducing a bill called stop the
militarizing of our law enforcement
because it moves us closer one step
closer to tyranny and it shreds our
civil liberties because what ends up
happening is when you give Police
Department's this overwhelming force you
shred the Fourth Amendment you shred the
Eighth Amendment police departments
excuse me and you may put it and you
make the Lima apartment the judge
during and the executioner I take away
beautiful take away due process
beautiful poem lacking all evidence well
here we shredding at news shredding all
of these all of these the free speech is
anti far the people that are going out
or whatever our next segment but we are
let's not mix and match yo what's happen
where you here is your energy anything
me here are stopping over little over
what happens what happens to my
mirandizing people not all this goes
away when police officers can drive down
an American city with a tank that's what
happens that's exactly what happened in
Ferguson to peaceful protest my god
which is why we lo got run over by a
tear with tear gas and there was tense
rolling down American Eagle every play
says dear dad we gotta move on